i want to fight jake it's just
obviously because of this whole pandemic
it's just literally just
[ __ ] it all right um yeah that's
interesting because
[Music]
what is it jake and logan they fight at
the same weight
yeah sorry the cruiserweight is though
everyone fights what is cruiserweight
yeah that's not in the ufc so i don't
know that
so that's uh it's about uh i'm
probably going to this one i think it's
around 82 kg or 81 kg
225 90 yeah kg so i don't know what
that's in pounds
right i mean dude that that's what makes
sense to me it's like
all right like if if anybody wants to
hate on
you know youtubers boxing
then like don't watch yeah
first off don't watch and and [ __ ] it
like i like that that you get respect
from like legitimate
fighting media like ariel helwani like
yo let's give these people
credit there's an audience for it you
know like i [ __ ] paid
five bucks to watch the the first logan
paul fight with the
with you yeah yeah i mean even though
you guys hate each other's it was only
five bucks right
like two um i think i think so yeah five
or ten yeah
it was it wasn't like i think it might
yeah it might have been ten it might
have been ten but yeah it was [ __ ]
it was great yeah dude